des joies des déceptions des
performances 700 rameurs se sont donné
rendez-vous à mantes-la-jolie ce
week-end de la toussaint l'occasion de
la coupe de france des régions donc
chaque région fait une sélection de ses
meilleurs cadets de ses meilleurs
juniors et de ses meilleurs seniors est
présenti fi des effectifs de 16 rames
heures par catégorie d'âge et concours
en quatre et en 8es cumul des points au
fur et à mesure des régates le
rendez-vous était programmé pour la
troisième fois consécutive sur le stade
nautique international didier simon
cette année des têtes d'affiché avaient
fait le déplacement on a en particulier
tous les médaillés voir les champions du
monde juniors qui sont là et qui
représente leur ligue on a également des
olympiens qui qui sont présents et qui
ont tenu à démontrer leur attachement
aussi à la ligue leur ligue de
rattachement ou l'arc club de
rattachement c'est finalement la région
grand est qui a remporté cette 29e
édition après deux jours de compétition
en fait c'est vraiment chaque course la
faire à fond et c'est tout en un peu
difficile de remonter sur l'eau et dire
il faut se faire mal et tout mais en
fait on est tellement motivé il ya
tellement une formulation que bas au
final bas on y va à fond quoi
rendez vous l'année prochaine à mantes
la jolie pour une nouvelle édition